Let's divide 3,771 by 8.
So we're going to do a
little bit of long division
is the way we set it up.
So the first thing we
want to do and think
about is, well,
does 8 go into 3?
Well, no, 8 does not go into 3.
So we'll keep moving.
Does 8 go into 37?
Sure.
8 times 4 is 37.
8 times 5 is 40.
So that's too big.
So 8 goes into 37 four times.
4 times 8 is 32.
And we subtract, and we
get 37 minus 32 is 5.
And just so you have a little
glimpse of what's actually
going on here,
we're really saying
how many times does
8 go into 3,700?
And we're saying that 8
goes into 3,700 400 times.
There's 4 sitting in
the hundreds place,
and that 400 times 8 is 3,200.
And then when you subtract 3,200
from 3,700, you're getting 500.
But we'll revert back to just
the traditional long division
mechanics.
But that's what's
really going on here.
When we say 8 goes
into 37 four times,
we're really saying 8
goes into 3,700 400 times.
But let's keep going.
So now, we have
this 5 to deal with,
which is, as we
already talked about,
it's in the hundreds place.
It's really a 500.
But now, let's bring
down another place value.
So let's bring down the 7.
And let's think about how
many times does 8 go into 57.
And we're really thinking
about how much 8 goes into 570.
But 8 goes into 57-- let's
see, 8 times 5 is 40.
8 times 6 is 48.
8 times 7 is 54.
So let's go 7 times.
7 times 8.
Oh, actually, I did that right.
8 times 7-- my multiplication
tables are weak.
It is 8 times-- so it
does go in seven times.
But 7 times 8 isn't 54; it's 56.
I always have trouble
with that one.
It is 56.
And so now, we subtract again.
And 57 minus 56 is 1.
And now we have one more
place value to bring down.
We have-- let me do it in in
a color I haven't used yet.
I'll do blue.
We have a 1 to bring down.
And now we're literally
saying, how many times
does 8 go into 11?
Well, 8 goes into 11 one time.
1 times 8 is 8.
And we are left
with-- because we
have no more places to bring
down-- 11 minus 8 is 3.
So 8 goes into 3,771 471 times,
and the remainder here is 3.